toria liste alexis poulain bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous on ne s'attendait
pas vraiment à ce type de tribune
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur qui
s'adresse directement aux journalistes
on ne comprend pas trop l'intention de
christophe castaner est-ce que sur la
forme déjà il n'y a pas une forme de
maladresse
il y a une énorme maladresse et c'est
extrêmement malesan de lire cette
déclaration d'amour les journalistes ne
demande pas des déclarations d'amour
déplacés il demande un cadre législatif
qui leur permet d'exercer leur métier
sans crainte de répression sans crainte
d'être mis en garde à vue sans crainte
d'autres pressions or là c'est tout
l'inversé c'est à dire qu'on a ce
registre de l'émotion utilisée par un
ancien ministre responsable de nombreux
blessés lors des manifestations des
gilet jaune qui osent utiliser ce
registre le ton badin presque de
l'humour en disant ne vous inquiétez pas
nous vous et moi vous allez pouvoir
continuer de faire votre métier
nous ne voulons pas vous censurez c'est
faux bien entendu puisque derrière
l'article 24 il ya la volonté des
cornées la loi sur la liberté de la
presse de 1881 qui est bien fait il faut
rappeler pendant la sphère benalla cette
affaire qui a fait trembler le pouvoir
les perquisitions au sein du journal en
ligne mediapart
la convocation d'une journaliste du
monde ariane chemin devant la sécurité
extérieure
plus récemment encore suite à la
décapitation de samuel pâtit la
convocation d'un journaliste de
libération
on voit bien que derrière ces
déclarations extrêmement déplacé il y a
la volonté de contrôler la presse de
l'encadrer et je ne vais pas vous
rappeler d'ailleurs que les journalistes
de rtl france sont toujours interdits
des conférences de presse de l'elysée
emmanuel macron un rapport
particulièrement délicat difficile avec
la presse libre il n'aime pas quand on
fait du contrechamp quand on va prendre
des photos là où on n'a pas le droit de
les prendre
la dernière photo du gouvernement castex
a été racontée par un photographe de
libération qui a expliqué qu'ils étaient
encadrés par un service d'ordre pour
prendre une seule photo officielle
quasiment et qu'il n'avait pas le droit
de faire son métier au sein même de
l'elysée qui est le palais présidentiel
la housse incarne l'institution
donc c'est extrêmement grave et je crois
que cette déclaration d'ailleurs est
très mal reçu par l'ensemble de la
profession mais
si par l'ensemble des citoyens par les
mots utilisés vous pouvez continuer deux
égratigné christophe castaner c'est ce
ministre inquiet or ni plus de dizaines
de personnes de gilet jaune qui ont
perdu un oeil lors des manifestations
suite à un tir de l bd dans leur tête
vous faites le lien direct entre le chef
de l'état et christophe castaner vous
pensez qu'il a été orientée poussé à
écrire cette tribune là ou alors aller
le fait d'une initiative toute
personnelle je ne sais pas mais
l'initiative personnelle est assez rare
dans ce quinquennat ou tout vient
finalement du bureau d'alexis colère ou
d'emmanuel macron quasiment la sphère du
syndicat lycéen pour jean-michel
bancaire on découvre que ce sont les
jeunes avec macron qui ont été une
façade pour ce faux syndicats potemkine
donc on voit bien que tout est organisé
la riposte 1 pour alexandre bédat là
qu'ils avaient été organisés du bureau
d'alexis colère et à l'époque d'autres
conseillers des mâles et le maquereau
qui avait organisé la riposte depuis
l'elysée c'est un scandale d'état
donc on voit bien que la centralisation
du pouvoir tels que les initiatives
individuelles sont rares et et écrire
une tribune de se tenir là sur la
liberté de la presse avec les
revirements du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin ministre actuel qui le
mardi disait que les journalistes
devaient aller se sont enregistrées
auprès de la préfecture pour couvrir des
manifestations et qui le vendredi dit
non en fait on va pas changer les lois
vous inquiétez pas tout va bien donc on
voit bien qu'au delà de l'amateurisme
fier de ces gens là il ya une volonté de
nuire une volonté d'encadrer de
contrôler la liberté de la presse pour
en faire une presse quasiment aux ordres
parce que il y a une habitude en france
et c'est pas seulement emmanuel macron
mais vraiment une presse de cours qui
est entretenue qui a ses entrées à
l'elysée où l'on déjeune où l'on dîne
avec des ministres quand on est
journaliste mondain et où on écrit
finalement pour continuer une propagande
officielle
c'est d'ailleurs une question qui peut
être posé sur le jdd ou tribune après
tribune ce journal qui appartient au
groupe lagardère s'est fait l'écho des
pouvoirs en place pas seulement macro
nismo si nicolas sarkozy dans le procès
s'ouvre demain et aucune ligne dans le
journal du dimanche par exemple donc la
lie la hiérarchie de l'info elle est
faite d'une certaine façon et on voit
bien que les politiques en france ont
une certaine habitude d'une presse
courtisane
qui qui leur donne une très mauvaise
idée de la presse il suffit d'aller voir
à l'étranger comment les journalistes
sont beaucoup plus violents et radicaux
vis-à-vis des politiques et de leurs
l'autre fait que news christophe
castaner rappelez vous c'est celui qui
disait que des manifestants étaient
entrés avaient saccagé un hôpital lors
d'un acte des gilets jaunes
c'était une fille qui use officielle
celle d'un ministre de l'intérieur et le
rôle des journalistes est bien c'est
d'attaquer s'effectue news qui sont
simplement de la propagande officielle
est-ce qu'on peut évoquer aussi l'art et
cette tribune forme de mélange des
genres qui finalement ne peut que que
risquait d'attiser un peu plus encore
les tensions avec la majorité est ce que
c'est le rôle du patron des députés la
république en marche d'écrire ce genre
de tribunes et fier à une autre question
aussi alexis blanc est ce qu'il y a une
intention politique est ce qu'il y à une
posture là de la part de christophe
castaner oui alors ça pose est
évidemment question sur la manière dont
cette majorité se veut hégémonique c'est
à dire que c'est c'est pléthore de
député en marche qui sont souvent
appelés des pousses boutons ou des
playmobil par certains même si pour
certains c'est une insulte qui ne
réfléchissent pas aux dangers de leur
vote pour les droits fondamentaux des
citoyens et le cadre de l'état de droit
avec certains députés qui sont même à
vouloir contester l'autorité du conseil
constitutionnel en disant qu'il faudrait
avoir un droit de réponse pour passer
outre les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel parce qu heureusement
que des institutions veille aux
institutions quand on a une majorité
comme celle ci est en rappelez vous la
loi bien sûr les discours de haine en
ligne avait été totalement censuré par
le conseil constitutionnel qui l'avait
jugée anticonstitutionnelle donc oui il
ya une volonté politique de vous faire
croire que cette majorité est garante
des droits et des lois alors que non il
y à une assemblée à la fois l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat avec des
oppositions avec beaucoup de courants
différents et je crois qu'il est temps
que au sein de la majorité beaucoup de
députés se réveille se rendent compte de
la charge qui est la leur de leur devoir
aussi de défendre les libertés dans
notre pays est aujourd'hui les lois qui
sont votées par cette majorité font tout
à fait inverse malgré ces tribunes
extrêmement mal écrite est dangereuse
parce que sur le thon justement à la
fois de l'humour
et du sentiment d'un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur devenu maintenant chef de la
majorité c'est extrêmement déplacé merci
beaucoup pour votre regard alexis poule
ans